[Musica]
con questa frase botero spiega
esattamente quello di cui vogliamo
parlarvi noi oggi ossia di come per noi
il confrontarsi si è diventato un modo
per moltiplicare le opportunità
ma facciamo un passo indietro
sicuramente scommetto che chiunque tra
di voi si è sentito chiedere da piccolo
cosa vuoi fare da grande tu margherita
cosa risponde v beh io a 6 anni volevo
fare la ballerina e infatti venti anni
dopo sono un ingegnere coerente devo
dire beh perché tu vorresti dirmi che
sei anni già volevi fare la designer no
hai ragione
in realtà volevo farla cuoca ma poi ho
cambiato idea
forse perché la cucina non era la mia
unica passione mi piaceva anche la
storia il cinema ma anche inventare e
realizzare con le mie mani giochi
oggetti nuovi e per questo ho studiato
design e com'è che tu sei finita
ingegneria dei materiali
beh mi è sempre piaciuta l'idea di
progettare qualcosa utilizzando la
matematica che è sempre stata un po la
mia passione però nel momento in cui mi
sono trovata a sfogliare quelle guide in
cui descrivono tutte le ingegnerie
disponibili
mi sono anche trovata davanti questo
corso in cui spiegavano come produrre i
materiali e come utilizzarli al meglio e
in realtà è solamente dopo questi cinque
anni di università che mi sono trovata
davanti alla scelta di cosa fare
veramente del mio futuro è spinta dalla
voglia di continuare a sperimentare il
laboratorio ho deciso di continuare con
dottorato di ricerca
ed è proprio da qui il punto da cui
vogliamo partire oggi dopo qualche
giorno dall'inizio di questo dottorato
mi viene comunicato che durante tutto il
percorso avrei dovuto collaborare con
una seconda persona un designer
sì adesso vi chiederete perché tutta
questa perplessità però nella mente di
un ingegnere come immaginavo è un
designer così quindi capite insomma un
creativo che magari usa anche i tavoli
come sedie
sede come tavoli e che passa tutto il
suo tempo durante il giorno a disegnare
bozzetti di cose che nella maggior parte
dei casi non verranno mai realizzate
grazie comunque
prego ma tornando a noi inizia ad
esserci un via vai di pensieri e di
domande nella mia mente la prima che mi
faccio è ma cosa faccio se per caso un
giorno mi arriva con un bozzetto magari
costituito da due linee veloci e mi
chiede di realizzare quello che vedo o
peggio ancora se mi fermasse per ore e
ore a discutere del tono di colore
troppo troppo poco brillante mi rendo
conto in quel momento che avrei avuto
ben poco in comune con questa seconda
persona come potete immaginare questo
designer sono io e diciamo puoi
confermarlo anche a loro che finora
hanno anche ho presentato alcun bozzetto
da esaminare sono infatti una designer
atipica invece che passare il mio tempo
a disegnare o inventare nuovi progetti
selezioni materiali per dar forma a
nuovi prodotti è un po come entrare in
una cabina armadio e scegliere quale
vestito mettere per una determinata
occasione ma fin dall'università ci
viene insegnato che in questo processo
di scelta
non siamo i soli in realtà veniamo
spesso supportati da alcune figure
piuttosto singolari di sesso maschile
prevalentemente che cercheranno di
metterti in difficoltà sempre con una
domande tecniche e possibilmente legate
a formule matematiche
chi sono gli ingegneri a me è capitata
lei e devo ammettere che anch'io
all'inizio del dottorato ho avuto più di
qualche pensiero e la paura di essere
continuamente interrogata sulla tavola
periodica quindi non sapendo bene come
iniziare questo dialogo abbiamo
cominciato a confrontarci su una
conoscenza che avevamo in comune
lui lui non è il nonno di nessuna delle
due nessun parente in comune lui è il
professor michael ashby dell'università
di cambridge
e dell autore di numerosi testi su cui
entrambe abbiamo studiato materiali ma è
anche il primo che ha capito che
combinare il punto di vista di designer
e l'ingegnere permette di ampliare la
conoscenza sui materiali che ci
circondano
in realtà è proprio collaborando su
questo argomento che abbiamo capito come
unire diverse prospettive di una stessa
disciplina o di uno stesso oggetto sia
molto più utile perché ci aiuta a
moltiplicare le informazioni in possesso
e soprattutto a capire veramente di cosa
stiamo parlando
ma capisco che è un concetto un po
complesso da spiegare quindi vorremmo
cercare di chiarirlo con un esempio
molto molto semplice partiamo da questa
immagine cosa vedete in questa foto
senza dubbio una mela rossa
confermo ma cosa sarebbe successo se
invece l'avessimo vista esattamente
dalla parte opposta avremmo visto questo
quindi è solamente quando uniamo le due
prospettive di uno stesso oggetto che
riusciamo a capire cosa stiamo
osservando sì una mela rossa ma tagliata
a metà è un po anche il punto da cui
siamo partite noi io riuscivo a vedere
una metà della mela e agnese l'altra ma
cosa ne pensi se cerchiamo di fargli
toccare con mano davvero queste due
visioni e come noi uniamo queste due
visioni
proviamo allora vi chiedo di fare questo
esperimento mettetevi nei miei panni
quelli di una designer che deve
scegliere il materiale migliore per
rendere più piacevole un oggetto allora
sicuramente avrete al collo o comunque
nella vostra borsetta un cordino come
questo vi chiedo di prenderlo in mano
così quindi toglietelo dal collo se lo
avete perfetto poi vi chiedo di chiudere
gli occhi
vi prometto che non vi lanceremo niente
addosso fidatevi di noi chiudete gli
occhi e cominciate a far scorrere tra le
vostre mani cordino ora se ad occhi
chiusi
mi dovessi chiedere come descrivereste
questo cordino tra liscio e ruvido cosa
direste
bene molti dicono ruvido se invece
sempre ad occhi chiusi
vi chiedessi caldo freddo come
descrivereste ecco qui siete un po meno
d'accordo ora potete riaprire gli occhi
l'esperimento però non è finito perché
se vi dovesse chiedere per esempio come
giudichereste alla vista questo cordino
probabilmente verrebbero fuori aggettivi
diversi nomi diversi magari correlati al
suo colore o alla sua forma quindi
capite che un designer nel momento di
scelta di un materiale deve tenere in
considerazione le diverse sensazioni che
un materiale potrà restituire e vi
invito a rifare l'esperimento a casa ea
ripetere magari con altri materiali dal
legno al vetro alla plastica questo
esperimento è sì ad occhi aperti che ad
occhi chiusi e capirete che ad ogni
materiale corrisponde una sensazione
diversa
questo perché i materiali sono
caratterizzati da differenti proprietà
sensoriali
adesso tocca a me prego grazie vi chiedo
adesso di mettermi nei miei panni quelli
di un ingegnere dei materiali
quindi utilizzeremo lo stesso cordino
che avete utilizzato adesso con agnese
ma lo prendiamo
devo cercare col microfono di fare delle
due estremità in questo modo con le mani
e cerchiamo di tirarlo come per romperlo
ma attenzione perché vedo in seconda
fila a qualcuno che ne sa gomitata al
attenzione al vicino vorremmo che
arrivasse a fine di tutte le tecniche
comunque tornando a noi se adesso io vi
chiedessi come descrivereste questo
materiale cosa rispondereste esatto non
rispondereste più lisce o ruvido caldo
freddo come vi ho detto agnese piuttosto
resistente perché spero che nessuno di
voi l'abbia veramente rotto e oppure per
esempio flessibile perché lo paghiamo
così in una maniera molto semplice
questo è un po l'approccio
ingegneristico allo studio alla
valutazione delle proprietà dei
materiali
e infatti questo materiale probabilmente
sarà stato scelto perché il progettista
chiamiamolo non voleva di certo che una
volta appeso
il nostro page che arrivasse magari a
livello dei piedi come abbiamo capito da
questo breve esperimento esistono
diversi approcci allo studio delle
stesse proprietà dei materiali ed
immateriali in genere però nonostante
questi approcci siano molto diversi
nulla toglie che non si escludono a
vicenda
esatto quello che cerchiamo tutti i
giorni di fare noi a combinare queste
due differenti visioni e punti di vista
un po come succede nel nell'intrecciare
trama ordito per realizzare un tessuto e
dall'intreccio appunto di queste nostre
due visioni e punti di vista
capiamo veramente la cos'è la
molteplicità delle proprietà dei
materiali per estendere però questo
concetto in maniera un po più ampia
quello che è importante anche se si
proviene da direzioni differenti e
magari opposte e trovare un punto in cui
incontrarsi e in cui confrontarsi
perché alla fine il confronto è un modo
per moltiplicare le opportunità grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]